vamos con el problema 37 en el problema
37 nos piden determinar el valor de xy x
menos 7 - jay-z
la pregunta esta sencilla vamos a ver
que nos dan de información en el
enunciado 1 nos dicen que es igual a 2
pero si sabemos que es igual a 2 no
sabemos mucho de esta expresión todavía
x y z pueden valer lo que sea y todavía
no tenemos suficiente información para
responder cuánto es esta expresión de
aquí entonces ésta por sí sola no es
suficiente vamos a ver qué dice el 2 en
el 2 tenemos que x menos zeta x menos
zeta es igual a 5 está solita pues
tampoco va a servir porque no nos dice
nada acerca de y entonces nuestra
esperanza es que al combinarlas nos den
la respuesta
bueno pues observemos que esta expresión
de aquí arriba la expresión que nos
preguntan la podemos factorizar y aquí
llega aquí y entonces podemos ponerla
como ye por x menos zeta sale
y observa que aquí nos dicen que es
igual a 2 entonces ya lo podemos cambiar
por 2 nos dicen que x
z es igual a 5 que este de aquí es 5 y
entonces podemos determinar cuánto es la
expresión que es igual a 10 pero no
teníamos que determinar la simplemente
teníamos que darnos cuenta que con las
dos con los dos incisos con los dos
enunciados podemos responder la pregunta
entonces la respuesta sería c y esto
quiere decir que cada uno de los
enunciados no es suficiente pero
juntando los sí podemos responder la
pregunta bueno ahora vayamos vamos al
problema 38 el problema 38 aquí tenemos
un dibujo déjame ver si me sale es más o
menos como un
un artefacto así que luego va para allá
parece como una manera o algo así seguro
ahorita que leamos el ejercicio va a
tener sentido y aquí tiene algo como
para agarrarse y aquí también creo que
eso no importa y nos dicen que esto mide
x que esto mide x ok dejame leer el
enunciado ahora si nos preguntan si los
primeros 10 tomos de una enciclopedia de
20 tomos van a caber en este librero
aunque es un librero
bueno pues información 1 nos dicen que x
x es igual a 50 centímetros esto por sí
mismo así solito pues no nos dice nada
acerca de si los tomos caben o no porque
ni siquiera habla acerca de cuánto miden
los tomos de la enciclopedia entonces
ésta por sí solita no sirve no sirve
vamos a ver qué dice la 2 en la 2 nos
dice que 12 de los tomos tienen una
media un grosor medio de 5 centímetros
entonces 12 tomos tomos
tiene un grosor grosor medio medio de 5
centímetros pero eso todavía no nos dice
gran cosa verdad o sea a lo mejor estos
12 tomos de los 20 son del 8 al 20 y
nosotros queremos poner los primeros 10
tomos entonces pues a lo mejor esta
información es de los tomos del 8 al 20
y los tomos del 1 al 10 o del 1 al 7 son
muy gordos y no caben aquí o son muy
flacos y si caben vayan no tenemos
información suficiente para concluir
nada entonces la respuesta sería y vamos
a ponerle aquí que la respuesta es y muy
bien pasemos ahora al problema 39 el
problema 39 tiene otro dibujo ahora es
como un cilindro entonces es algo más o
menos de este estilo algo así algo así
más o menos más o menos algo así y
además esto está unido para cada y esto
está unido para acá imagínate que es un
cilindro que me quedo derechito bueno
entonces tenemos ese cilindro y además
nos dibujan una banda en medio del
cilindro una banda como por acá
que se ve que recorre todo el cilindro
alrededor una banda sombreada y además
nos dicen que el alto de esa banda es x
metros x metros muy bien es esa de ahí
es la figura lo que nos preguntan es si
podemos determinar cuál es la superficie
de área de esta banda sigue por ahí
atrás cuál es la superficie que cubre
esta banda cuál es el área que cubre
esta banda vale bueno pues para
determinar esa superficie que cubre o
esa área pues necesitamos conocer su
altura y además el perímetro de la banda
para lo cual necesitamos el perímetro de
este círculo vamos a ver que nos dan de
información en el enunciado 1 nos dicen
que x es igual a 0.5 eso de ahí es
suficiente pues pues todavía no verdad
si conocemos esta altura todavía nos
falta conocer el perímetro entonces esta
sí solita no basta y en la información 2
nos dicen que la altura del cilindro de
todo este cilindro es 1 metro
un metro de altura o sea esta altura de
acá es un metro pero eso pues tampoco
sirve verdad eso de ahí tampoco sirve
porque necesitamos este perímetro y la
información que nos dan ni siquiera
adjuntando estos dos la información que
nos dan es suficiente para determinar
esta área va entonces la respuesta sería
y ahora si nos dieran por ejemplo el
diámetro de esta circunferencia o el
radio entonces podríamos calcular su
perímetro y con eso y con eso esta área
de acá pero por el momento no va ese fue
el problema 39 vamos al problema 40 el
problema 40 nos pide determinar el valor
del entero n entero entero
la información que nos dan en el inciso
1 es que n por n 1 es igual a 6 ok esta
de acá tiene truco hay que tener cuidado
nada más nos están diciendo que n es un
entero pero no nos dice nada acerca de
su signo entonces uno se puede ir con la
finta y decir ah pues la única
posibilidad aquí es que en ese a
igualados y que n uno sea igual a tres y
entonces 2 por 3 es igual a 6 y ya el
inciso 1 basto pero ojo no nos dicen que
en ese a positivo también podemos tener
que n es igual a menos 3 y que n 1 es
igual a menos 2 y con esto n por n
uno es menos 3 x menos 2 que también nos
da 6 vale entonces ahí tenemos dos
posibilidades con las cuales tenemos que
tener cuidado y por lo tanto hasta
ahorita todavía no tenemos información
suficiente no tenemos información
suficiente para determinar el valor de n
vamos a ver qué dice el inciso 2
el inciso 2 nos dice que 2 a las 2 n 2 a
2 n es igual a 16 16 un problema con
exponentes en casi todos los problemas
con exponentes de exámenes
estandarizados a casi a nivel prepa o
incluso secundaria la idea básicamente
es llevar todo a la misma base va
entonces aquí tenemos base 2 y tenemos 2
a la 12 n hay que poner a 16 como 2 al
algo bueno pues 16 es igual a 2 a la 4 y
esto nos dice que 12 n es igual a 4 y
por lo tanto n es igual a 2 dividiendo
entre 2 a ambos lados va excelente
entonces pues ya tenemos esta
información ya tenemos esta información
entonces pues tenemos el valor de n y
por lo tanto este segundo inciso fue
suficiente y el primero no entonces la
respuesta es b
se sabe que un poco fea está más o menos
bueno ese de allí fue el problema 40
vamos ahora al problema 41 problema 41
este está un poco largo déjame hacer
primero el dibujo que nos dan es más o
menos una caja así que tiene varios
círculos varios círculos ahí tiene uno
más o menos por ahí tiene otro
y ahí tiene otro se ve que son círculos
iguales y aquí no me está quedando muy
bien la figura pero en el que nos dan si
son círculos igualitos y tangentes entre
sí quizás un poco más para acá está más
o menos y de hecho esta figura la
dibujan continuando para allá y
continuando para acá
continuando para acá entonces quizás sea
buena idea que elimine estos lados de la
caja para no confundirnos bueno entonces
ahí tenemos lo que parece ser una caja
porque el enunciado dice aquí tenemos
una una caja rectangular que tiene 48
centímetros de largo quizás sea bueno
dibujarla ahora en perspectiva la voy a
poner por acá más o menos algo así
algo así a ver si no me queda muy chueco
algo así algo por acá y algo por acá
entonces dice tenemos una caja bueno
aquí tiene otra pared pero creo que se
ve la idea verdad entonces tenemos una
caja que tiene 48 centímetros de largo
aquí son 48 centímetros de largo que
tiene 32 centímetros de ancho 32
centímetros de ancho y 15 centímetros de
altura 15 centímetros de altura muy bien
y nos dicen que la caja se llena
totalmente con cada acá latas
gálatas idénticas cuya altura es de 15
centímetros 15 centímetros siguiendo el
patrón de la figura entonces bueno aquí
tenemos la caja vista del lado aquí
tenemos la caja vista desde arriba
podemos pensar que esto mide 48
centímetros que estoy acá mide 32
centímetros vale bueno todo eso es el
planteamiento y lo que ellos o lo que
les gustaría saber a los que hicieron el
examen es cuántas cajas caben entonces
nos preguntan por el valor de acá cuál
es el valor de acá vamos a ver que nos
dan de posibilidades de bueno de
información pues entonces la información
que nos dan en el inciso 1
es que cada una de las latas tiene un
radio de cuatro centímetros entonces
cada lata plata tiene radio
de cuatro centímetros eso será
suficiente para determinar cuántas latas
caben pues yo digo que si miras y
sabemos que cada lata tiene radio de
cuatro centímetros entonces esto mide
cuatro centímetros hacia el otro lado
mide cuatro centímetros
entonces el diámetro es ocho centímetros
y entonces de acá para acá abarca ocho
centímetros esta siguiente lata abarca
ocho centímetros y cuántas veces cabe
ocho en 48 pues 6 entonces aquí
tendríamos seguiríamos teniendo otra
lata otra lata y así hasta juntar seis
esas de ocho y esas son justo las que
caben así y luego tendríamos que ver
cuántas caben verticalmente
aquí tenemos 32 centímetros y vamos a
cubrir pues también con un diámetro de 8
verdad
cuántas veces cabe 8 en 32 pues 4 aquí
tendríamos en total cuatro latas
posibles por acá va otra
entonces con eso podríamos saber cuántas
latas son en total de este lado son 6 de
este lado son 4 entonces caben 48 48
latas entonces esta información si es
suficiente este problema está bien padre
verdad vamos vamos ahora con el inciso 2
en el inciso 2 nos dice que caben cada
vez 6 latas a lo largo
platas a lo largo a lo largo
entonces nos están diciendo que acaben 1
2 3 4 5 6 y no sabemos la información
del 1 solo sabemos eso pero solo
sabiendo eso o sea si nos dicen que
caben exactamente así apenitas y caben
entonces tenemos que esas 6 latas deben
de repartirse esos 48 centímetros pues
equitativamente entonces una vez más su
diámetro es de 8 centímetros y ahora
verticalmente pues otra vez porque
podemos argumentar que caben 4 entonces
el inciso 2 básicamente nos da la misma
información que el inciso 1 y con eso
podemos determinar cuántas latas son son
48 una vez más no teníamos que saber
cuántas eran nada más teníamos que saber
que esta información era suficiente para
saber cuántas eran es lo que me encanta
de esta prueba que no tenemos que hacer
la cuenta pero bueno ya vimos que son 48
entonces este nos permite responder este
nos permite responder y entonces la
respuesta es de ambos incisos nos
permiten responder por sí mismos